thanks for having me I think since we're
in a classroom setting as Mike said we
can make this very interactive I'll make
a few opening remarks and kind of sketch
out what we did and why we did it as
quickly as I can with the clock back
there to remind me what time it is and
then love to take your questions on on
any aspect of this just I'll start at
the end actually because when GM went
public that day I had agreed to co-host
CNBC and was sitting on the set of CNBC
as as the various GM executives and
floor people and the firt and the bell
rang and the first year was trade and
all that and it was an amazing moment
after all the ups and downs and all the
work and all the effort even though we
were it felt very good about what we had
done to actually see it validated by the
market was really it was really quite a
moment and but so before I go back in
time I do want to just amplify on Mike's
recognition of clay Calhoun who's
sitting over here because you'll all
want to read this book because clay is
very prominently mentioned in it he's
actually in the index but I just want to
I want to just read one paragraph about
this came up in the sort of middle and
the frenzy when we were trying to get
Chrysler and Fiat all on the same page
and they had different sets of
projections and and we basically said
you guys have a weekend to figure this
thing out and I didn't want to spend the
weekend in Detroit Ron blew my deputy
didn't want to spend the recant weekend
in Detroit so we sent clay and and
another fellow called Brian Esaias and
so this little paragraph begins on
Saturday morning so by by 11:00 a.m. on
Saturday morning Osias and Calhoun
convened more than two dozen Fiat and
Chrysler executives and advisors around
the large table in Chrysler's 15th floor
boardroom the executives were almost all
middle-aged industry veterans Osias was
32 years old and Calvin was 26 and both
looked younger than their years we're
going to sit at this table until we're
done Calhoun announced
there's much more about clay here you
should all get this book and and read it
to find all as I'm sorry I didn't mean
to embarrass you like that but clay clay
was clay and I work together at
quadrangle and he was a superstar there
and so when I went to Washington to take
this job and he said you know asked me
if we were looking for help and I said
we're looking for all kinds of help and
I was really delighted that he joined us
and like all the rest of our team he did
a he did a fabulous job so let me let me
just as I said try to do two things in a
short amount of time and so I'll speak
reasonably quickly and then we can it
open up let me just give you a kind of a
quick chronology for those of you who
didn't follow autos all that closely and
I can't blame you for not and then let
me give you a few sort of of the
takeaways from the project that I would
I would love you to all leave the room
thinking about and and then as I said we
can have a discussion I think probably
most of you remember the sort of first
big public event in the auto crisis in
November of 2008 when the three
executives flew to Washington to testify
in front of Congress and their separate
planes and that's the part everybody
remembers what people don't remember as
well as they showed up having GM and
Chrysler particularly having kind of
frankly suddenly discovered that they
were about to run out of money having
justice suddenly told the bush
administration they were running out of
money and then appearing and then being
sent to Congress by secretary Paulson
and appearing there with essentially no
plan no idea what they were going to do
with the money and no sort of
recognition of any sort of culpability
in in the fact that they had run out of
money there was a lot of chewing and
throwing at the end of 2008 obviously
there had been a presidential election
it was a lame duck administration there
was a banking crisis going on but
President Bush and Congress ultimately
just failed to act they just couldn't
pull themselves together to do anything
about autos at that point President Bush
in my opinion quite correctly made a
decision that auto the auto companies
were not going to fail on his watch and
so one of his kind of swat teams of x
goldman guys that he brought in
sort of pulled together in December of
2008 and and provided bridge loans of
about seventeen billion dollars to GM
into Chrysler to sort of get them over
the end of the year get them into 2009
when the new team was going to arrive
and would hopefully then have the time
the bandwidth or just kind of the energy
frankly to address the problem and as I
said I think given the situation at that
point the end of an eight-year
presidency a lot of very tired people
I think the bush people did about as
good a job as you can do under the
circumstances
president-elect Obama then of course
realized that he had to he had to deal
this deal with this problem and after
some deliberation decided they would set
up a separate task force to do this they
there were two reasons really for that
one the they knew that the economic and
financial crisis was going to occupy all
of the people who had sort of the
traditional jobs of Undersecretary of
this or assistant secretary of that
within Treasury within commerce within
the White House and the second reason
they did it which is an interesting
reflection on how our government works
is that we had no auto expertise in the
government really for that matter we had
no real industrial expertise and I don't
say that critically but in this country
relative to some European countries and
other countries we really have tried to
stay out as a government from the
industrial sector and so part of that is
not really having people whose job it is
is to understand industry in general or
even specific industries and so there
are a couple people in the Commerce
Department who kind of monitored auto
imports and we later found out there are
a few people over at the Fed who
actually were pretty good at forecasting
auto sales in general but they were
really there was really nobody in the
entire government who knew anything
about autos and of course I didn't know
any better autos either but that's a
different that's a different a different
matter
so they decided to set up this team and
they did come to me and so you may say
why did they come to me and that would
be a very valid question and the short
answer is because Tim Geithner and Larry
you know the two guys who clay and I and
the rest of our team worked for directly
as well as obviously indirectly the
president they had the view that this
was not a management job we were not
being hired to run these companies we
were not being hired and decide what the
next new car should be or what cars they
should make it was really a financial
restructuring exercise we were being
hired and a private equity exercise for
that matter we were being hired to
basically look at these companies and
figure out how to take them from the
disastrous place they were and
restructure them into something that
could be viable and by the way we knew
that we were going to be making a very
significant additional investment of
government money and so it was a private
equity exercise in the sense that we
were investing all of your money
taxpayers money and we needed to try to
figure out whether this was a good
investment or not and be able to tell
the president and his other senior
advisors in the White House what we
thought was likely was likely to happen
so they looked at me and and clay and
the rest of us who ultimately arrived as
a restructuring team I was not the most
experienced restructuring guy in the
world either but because of my political
involvement they felt that since this
was going to be an exercise that
occurred in the political arena even
though there was a great commitment to
having it being done in a thoughtful way
that having someone who had a sense of
the politics of it all would be helpful
as well as as well as the financial
hopefully the financial skills we were
on an incredibly tight timeframe because
as I said they had been given a
relatively small amount of money 17
billion dollars to get them through
essentially the first quarter of 2009
through the end of March so I didn't
really even start doing anything until
January of 2009 my appointment wasn't
announced till late February of 2009 the
rest of the team really didn't come
together until early March of 2009 you
guys take a seat if you want until March
of 2009 and so we were operating on this
really tight timeframe tighter than
any project I think I've ever worked on
and with a relatively small team we
ended up with 14 of us mostly people
like lei and me who had come from Wall
Street because they wanted to serve but
some policy people as well and that by
the standards of what we were being
asked to do was an exceptionally small
team I remember one of my reservations
about taking the job was how are we
gonna find the people and get the people
we needed to do this and Larry summer
said to me in one of my early meetings
how many people do you think you need
and I said you know in a private sector
context I think 50 here you know maybe
15 he said well my whole staff is only
19 and I said well that may be but we
need 15 to do this job and so we ended
up having 14 we got essentially what we
needed but it was as I said I think
JPMorgan you mentioned David Hopper was
working on this in Morgan Stanley and
they had dozens and dozens of people so
it was a very very lean team from the
beginning there were two principles that
the president and Larry Summers and Tim
Geithner decided it was that were really
critical to our efforts to the success
of our efforts the first was that the
only money that we wanted to put in and
hope to put in was in the context of a
fundamental restructuring make the
companies viable they decided and I was
really pleased that they did that they
didn't want to kick the can down the
road anymore they didn't want to try to
paper it over they didn't want to try to
just get to the next election they
wanted whatever we did they wanted it to
be something that made these companies
viable again and the second important
principle that we established early on
and and they stood by throughout this
was a shared sacrifice that this was not
going to be done on the backs of the UAW
alone it was not going to be done on the
backs of the creditors alone or on the
dealers or the suppliers but that we
were going to try to get everybody to
the table and get everybody to recognize
that they were not the only ones were
being asked to sacrifice and that turned
out both of those principles turned out
to be very important ones
so we plunged in as I've acknowledged I
didn't know
about autos so we approach this with a
fresh eyes we've had all kinds of every
expert wanted to come and tell us their
views about the auto industry we met
with an awful lot of them we listened to
everybody's thoughts we push back we
certainly spent time with the companies
this is all sort of now in March of 2009
because we knew that by the end of March
the President had to tell the country
what he was going to do about the auto
situation and by March 25th or so we had
pretty much the essential elements ready
for the president to decide the toughest
decision that the president had to make
really was whether to save Chrysler or
not we we knew pretty well that we were
going to save GM GM was too big too
important and an A and what we thought
of as a real company that needed to be
saved
Chrysler was a tougher call it was as
you know probably the third largest and
third of three American auto companies
it was only a North American player it
had been owned for seven years by
Daimler and then for a couple of years
by Cerberus and had been pretty well
hollowed out it didn't have a single car
that was on Consumer Reports most
recommended lists and there was a strong
part of our group that actually made a
very passionate and very logical and
analytically sound argument that
Chrysler should be led to fail that what
was capitalism about if not letting me
companies fail why was the government
putting a lot of money into an old
industry company and I guess I should
recognize that I'm in the heart of new
industry land here and so maybe you all
don't think we should have saved any
auto companies but put the money in
Google instead but but but there was
that argument that if the government has
limited dollars which of course it has
they should be allocated to newer
industries that might have greater
growth prospects on the other side of
the argument the economy was losing six
or seven hundred thousand jobs a month
at this point the immediate impact of
Chrysler shutting down would have been
around 300,000 jobs lost only small part
of those from Chrysler itself but you
then had suppliers or dealers you had
all the people who serviced these
this company and so on and while I don't
believe that we would have saved
Chrysler simply because of those jobs as
I said if we determined that Chrysler
was not viable I think we I think the
president would have agreed with a
recommendation to let it liquidate but
after a lot of hard work I think
everybody on the team agreed that
Chrysler could be viable and that the
government could get its money back from
Chrysler it was more a question of
whether it was it was some of the
government should do among the points
that the people who thought Chrysler
should be allowed to go made was that if
Chrysler went out of business what we
learned as we learned about the industry
was that a disproportionate amount of
Chrysler sales would have gone to
fording GM relative to the foreign
companies because the product lineup of
Chrysler minivans trucks things like
that where they were strongest lined up
best with Ford and GM so in effect we
knew we were going to be a big
shareholder in GM or a big investor
anyway by letting Chrysler go we would
make the value of that investment
greater but of course then you'd have
all those jobs lost so it was a very
passionate hard-fought debate that went
really as I said right to the president
and to two meetings in the White House
on the 25th or 6th of March and at the
end of hearing at all the president came
down where a slight majority of our
group had come down which was to provide
Chrysler with additional money if it
could meet a series of very tough tests
in terms of concessions in terms of a
business plan that we could back in
terms of an alliance with Fiat because
we didn't feel that Chrysler could exist
simply as a North American player we
felt it needed a global alliance and
Fiat was the company that had come
forward that we thought made the most
sense and so it was still not a done
deal but at least all things being
accomplished the president agreed that
we would that we would save save
Chrysler so he gave the speech on March
30th that probably all of you remember
in addition to the announcement about
Chrysler and the announcement that we
were gonna try to save GM but still had
work to do he also announced
that Rick Wagner was going to be
stepping down as chairman of GM this to
us was the most obvious decision that
the president had to make GM had lost
thirty billion dollars of cash in the 15
months of 2008 and the first quarter of
2009 as I said earlier when when Rick
appeared in front of the Senate in
November of 2008 there was no plan there
was no sense of responsibility it didn't
get any better the plan that GM
submitted us in February of 2009 still
didn't show us that they had a sense as
to how they were going to become
profitable and viable again and we
simply believed that under those
circumstances and needed to be a change
in management Rick is a very decent
hard-working smart guy who was totally
dedicated to the company but we were
thinking about this in a private equity
contexts in which management really does
matter and so we felt and recommended to
the president that there be a change in
management and with really almost no
discussion which has not meant as any
disrespect to Rick the president agreed
with that I Mike was nice enough to hand
out an article I wrote recently about
the role of management which related to
Steve Jobs this last leave of absence
and I'm happy to talk about that a bit
in the Q&A because one of the things
I've always believed in both the
investment banking in the private equity
business is that the jockey is as
important as the horse that it's
important to have a good business but
who the CEO is and who the top
management team are is also important
and so we felt that we could not really
recommend in good conscience to the
president putting more money into GM
unless there was a change in change in
management so as everybody knows we
ended up putting both companies into
bankruptcy a lot of folks said it
couldn't be done a lot of folks said
that we broke bankruptcy law we made new
law or we the heavy hand of government
I'm happy to talk about all that but
needless to say we believe that
everything we did was in conformity with
the law in fact it was litigated all the
way to the Supreme Court I don't think
when I went to Washington I ever
imagined that I was be worrying about a
Supreme Court decision as part of my job
but there we were
and at the end it was all approved in
every step of the way and we got GM and
Chrysler in and out of bankruptcy in
essentially record time 42 days for
Chrysler and 39 days for GM I think as
you know since then it's worked out
quite well we talked about the GM IPO
briefly but the GM IPO simply symbolized
the recovery that the two companies have
made the bankruptcy process was really
essential to giving these companies a
fresh start in the case of GM we took
their liabilities from one hundred and
twenty billion dollars to 55 billion
dollars we took 8 billion dollars a year
of operating annual operating costs out
of their North America division and this
was all accomplished by the kind of
shared sacrifice that I alluded to
before in which everybody came to the
table willing to make you know
grudgingly it was hard-fought it was
difficult but in the end willing to make
changes I remember one of our early
meetings with the UAW when Ron gentle
finger who was then the president said
to us and actually this is in Detroit at
solidarity house said to us look we're
willing to do something here because I I
wrong gentle finger understand that if
we don't cooperate these companies may
disappear but we feel like we've been
asked to sacrifice in the past which
they had and we feel like we're the only
ones who've been asked to sacrifice and
we want to see other people asked to
sacrifice and so it was that concept of
shared sacrifice that allowed us to make
more progress with with the cost
structure liability structure these
companies then people have been able to
make before it really a lot of it
relates back to that famous saying of
Rahm Emmanuel's which actually was not
his but he's said who said it first but
I can't remember which has never let a
crisis go to waste that we had this
atmosphere of crisis we had everybody
realizing that without pulling together
and making this work it it would be a
disaster and so we were fortunate to
have that going for us one of the other
principles that we established early on
was that the government was going to get
in
get out as quickly as possible it was
gonna be kind of the opposite of Vietnam
we didn't want to be mired in the car
business and so we established early on
private sector boards for these
companies and it was and we really
looked for directors who had exactly the
right skills it wasn't an effort to
create a sort of Noah's Ark compendium
of two of everything it was an effort to
put together a mix of former CEOs and
private equity people who really could
oversee these companies and so as you
see GM and Chrysler going forward now
both very successfully a lot of the
credit goes not only to the to the new
management teams of the two companies
but also to the new boards of directors
who have been really tough and have just
instilled a whole new aura of corporate
governance at these companies GM in
particular had terrible corporate
governance one of our colleagues like -
I shouldn't say this in front of the
cameras but like to speak of the GM
directors and very disparaging terms and
happily you know we as I said have made
those those changes and the new
management teams have done a great job a
lot of these old industry practices some
of which actually had logic in terms of
the structural problems of the industry
led the companies to do things that made
no sense like have too much inventory on
the dealer's Lots like the famous
incentives and the zero financing and
all that stuff where they couldn't make
money in the end there were reasons why
they did all that it wasn't as crazy as
it seemed but by changing their balance
sheets and changing their cost
structures we essentially gave them a
reason to operate in a more logical
rational business way and that's what
they're doing inventories are under
control and sentence are under control
and most importantly through the
restructuring we dramatically changed
the breakeven of these companies so GM
prior to the restructuring really
couldn't make money unless 16 or 17
million cars a year was sold in this
country which is something that's only
occurred a few a few times in our
history after the restructuring and GM
could make money in a 10 or 11 million
car sale environment and so standing
here today with car sales running about
twelve and a half million
actually eleven and a half million for
last year GM last year had its first
annual profit since 2004 and its highest
profit since 1999 so even with car sales
still very depressed GM is making
substantial net income and Chrysler is
actually making pretty good operating
profits although not yet net income and
I continue to be very optimistic if for
no other very simple reason that we need
to sell 15 million cars a year in this
country simply to keep the fleet from
aging in other words to deal with
replacing cars on the road plus a small
addition of new drivers every year as
roughly a 15 million car sale rate for
the last three years we've been below
that well below that in 2008 and so we
this is the first time in history that
essentially more cars have been scrapped
that have actually been sold so that
whole situation is not is not a
long-term sustainable one in my opinion
and I think our sales will continue to
climb I think there'll be somewhere
between 13 and 14 million this year and
and then just keep going and given the
changes in the cost structure of these
companies they can make a lot of money
as GM already has as car sales go up
even just a little bit because of the
operating leverage that's inherent in
them so let me quickly run through sort
of what I think are the takeaways if you
kind of want to leave the room sort of
with a thought about what does this all
mean this is sort of what I think it all
means and I think I have about six of
them first that this really could not
have happened without the president's
insistence on shared sacrifice and on
only putting money and if the companies
could be viable that is not intended to
be a political you know statement or
endorsement or whatever I'm off the
government payroll it's what I actually
believe that without that kind of
support in the face of what a lot of
people thought would be enormous
pressure from labor for example to be
less tough I don't think we could have
done this
secondly we were able to do this for
that reason we were able to do this just
almost exactly as if we were in the
private sector as I said we approach
this as a private equity investment
exercise we made all the same kind of
visions and did the same kind of
analysis that we would have in the
private sector although you know
obviously in a different under a
different spotlight and and I think we
as a result invested the taxpayer
dollars wisely thirdly as I said before
contrary to what some of you may have
read or think and again happy to debate
it everything we did was not only legal
but in accordance with precedent and in
accordance with I think fair treatment
of of all the stakeholders forth as I
said you know management really really
matters and I mentioned the decision
about about Rick we made a similar
decision in the case of Chrysler that we
felt that management was critical and a
key part of the alliance with Fiat and
in deciding to partner up with Fiat was
the fact that Sergio Marconi was the CEO
of Fiat and Sergio who was not also a
lifelong auto guy had done a great job
of turning Fiat around which had been a
very troubled auto company had actually
done very poorly in the u.s. in
particular but but which they exited but
surger had done a great job and we
really felt that Sergio was a jockey
that we could bet on and so you now in
Detroit have this rather interesting
situation of three the so-called big
three which they now call the Detroit
three because they're not so big anymore
all being run by people who are not from
Detroit two of whom Mullally and Dan
Akerson who's the current CEO of GM are
not Auto guys and Sergio who was
certainly not a typical auto guy or a
lifelong auto guy and so even though we
certainly got a lot of blowback from the
auto community about who were we a bunch
of non auto guys and who was Ackerson
and you know and all this kind of stuff
I think that having I think having fresh
blood in this industry has turned out to
be the right decision Bill Ford who I
only met after this was all over because
Ford really was not under our care gave
a speech in about I think 2006 or 7
right about the time he brought Mullally
in which I mentioned in the book in
which he basic
we said we're an insular company in an
insular industry and insular town and it
was something that very few people in
Detroit would acknowledge or recognize
but Bill Ford did and made that decision
to bring in Alan Mulally and it was a
really smart decision it was a very
humble decision and I think it was a
very important moment of sort of
introspection on on Bill's apart the
fifth point I just want to leave you
with which is more of a Washington point
but I assume some of you are interested
in or all of you hopefully interested in
our political process works is that we
could not have done what we did without
the existence of tarp I'm sure you all
know what tarp is the seven hundred
billion dollar financial rescue fund
that was passed actually under President
Bush's watch even though President Obama
now gets blamed for it but it was it was
probably the single I call it the single
most important piece of economic
legislation in certainly my lifetime
because it gave the Secretary of the
Treasury the ability to deploy 700
million dollars was actually never all
used I think only about 450 billion was
used to save the financial sector and to
save the auto sector where we put eighty
two billion dollars without tarp either
administration both administrations
would have had would have had to have
gone to Capitol Hill for every
appropriation for every dollar that went
into the banks or they went into the
auto companies and having now spent a
good bit of time in Washington I have no
doubt that Congress would have never
pulled itself together to appropriate
that money in any kind of timely way and
you would have had a meltdown in the
banking sector we would have not had the
money to save the auto sector and all
the consequences that I alluded to
before about Chrysler would have
happened except multiplied I'm not here
to tell you that we shouldn't have
democracy I'm not here to to say that we
don't need a congress but it was a real
eye-opener for me
how difficult working with Congress can
be and how hard it is to get stuff done
and how much when people blame the
president either president
any president for the problems of this
country frankly they should be turning a
lot of their attention to Congress
because the president really has much
less power than you would imagine a lot
of our founding fathers were not you
know they had her they had a purpose in
mind in establishing Congress at the
Capitol on the top of the hill and the
president in the White House at the
bottom of the hill I wasn't a complete
accident
and so it's just something we all need
to think about you know Congress mostly
left us alone happily when they finally
focused on autos it was only because of
the dealers who you know we closed a lot
of dealers and Congress got infuriated
by that and so in the summer of 2009
they spent a lot of time having hearings
and calling us up to explain why this
dealer was being closed or that dealer
was being closed stuff that we actually
had nothing to do with and that was
being done thoughtfully but it was sort
of an odd juxtaposition that the one
time Congress decided to focus on autos
it was over dealers which in our minds
were not the central part of it
the last thing I I wanted that last
point I wanted to leave you with is that
this was really the first time I had
spent a lot of time in the manufacturing
sector you know clay and I did media and
telecom stuff at quadrangles most of
what I did in my career and you know we
could have a whole discussion about the
manufacturing sector but I did come away
really very much appreciating and even
scared about the state of our
manufacturing sector really not through
our fault but you know we are competing
in a global world now we're competing
against other countries that are very
good at getting better and better at
doing a lot of the things that we used
to be on our own level in doing and it's
it's had its impact on our manufacturing
sector in my opinion it's going to
continue to I'll give you just a couple
of quick little anecdotes that struck me
in the course of this that I talked
about in the book one was talking to
Fritz Henderson who was the CEO of GM
after Rick for a while and GM had plants
in Mexico adver has a very thriving
business in China and has operations in
India and I said Fritz what are you
buddy
pay outside the US so in the US the base
wage for UAW workers 28 dollars an hour
in Mexico they pay seven dollars an hour
in China they pay four dollars an hour
and in India they pay $1 an hour and I
said different so what's your
productivity like in Mexico and he said
it's a at least as good as the US maybe
better and so you know this is what
we're up against and the other sort of
vignette that's stuck in my mind that I
talked about in here was one day I think
it was in March sometime Delphi came in
to see us the executives of Delphi
Delphi as you all probably know was GM's
parts operation it was spun off by GM in
1999 they went bankrupt about three or
four years ago it was sort of sitting in
bankruptcy for several years and they
came in as one of the many suppliers who
came in to see us to tell us that they
were being kind of crushed by the
problems that she had Chrysler and could
we help them and so they were kind of
making their case for help and there
were some Delphi is based in Troy
Michigan they were very earnest you know
solid Midwestern kind of folks and I'm
listening and I don't know why it popped
into my head but at one moment I said
how many people do you guys employ and
the the numbers are here but the answer
was something like 135,000 and I said
and how many of them are in the US and
they said 15,000 so Delphi this
quintessential American company had
quietly carefully deliberately moved 90
percent of its workers offshore so this
is you know this is the challenge we
face in manufacturing and we can again
have a lively debate about whether we
should do more or less to help
manufacturing but I just think we should
be mindful of the fact that it is it is
a it is a challenge let me close because
probably some of you are wondering what
the scorecard was on our adventures in
auto land I mentioned that we invested
eighty two billion dollars in these
companies if you look at where GM stock
is trading now if you look at how GM
values at stake and Ally financial the
old GMAC which actually was our second
biggest investment after GM but larger
than Chrysler if you look at the
valuations that are out there on
Chrysler equity we got the US taxpayer
as we sit here today would recover about
85% of the
that was put up so in other words a loss
of potentially around ten billion
dollars I continue to believe that
there's a lot of upside in the sector
it's been a hit a bump in the road no
pun intended the last few weeks because
of the oil price stuff the shares are
down but I think generally the
trajectory will continue to be up and so
I think we could actually do better than
that
but even if we end up losing ten billion
dollars I would argue that ten billion
dollars was money well spent to save the
sector because not only would we have
lost Chrysler we would have lost GM we
would have lost the suppliers we would
have lost actually Ford because they
wouldn't been only get parts at least
for a while and it would have been an
economic calamity akin to what would
have happened if we hadn't saved the
banking sector and I think devastation
across much of the Midwest so I'm proud
of what we did I'm proud of the
president's decision to do what he did
and glad to be here to tell the story
and happy to spend what time we have
left on questions or comments extend you
played out what would happen under each
scenario because my intuition would say
that you would necessarily lose all that
that you know those assets are going
nothing to sit there like they're gonna
be bought by either foreign oil foreign
auto companies
for the party suppliers still need to
supply and there is a desert of
intrinsic demand for office so what it's
done do you have the sort of scorched
earth knowing what around or are these
they just transported different owners
how does that change the decisions that
you guys made question so with respect
to the overall decision to intervene we
honestly didn't have the time and we
were too terrified of what the result
would be to sort of say well what would
happen if we did nothing I've I just
gave you a real capsule at the end of
what I think would have happened if we
had done nothing which would have been
GM and Chrysler would have run out of
money at the end of March of 2009 they
would have closed their doors they would
have stopped paying people from having
seen the very nitty-gritty balance
sheets of these businesses they had
absolutely no idea how much e cash they
had know anything I know well the
alternative is he knew the government
was gonna ban him out so he needed to
spend all that money GM to toe with the
CEO it's kind of hard to see yeah I'm
gonna the CFO Furman this
oh yeah could not on any given day
tell us within 500 million dollars how
much cash they had they did not have the
systems to know as a result they said
they needed 11 billion dollars of cash
to operate and they should have been
operate on 6 billion dollars of cash or
someone umbral like that they didn't
know they really didn't know they don't
believe if did you know I mean you told
you you know more than the guys they
didn't have any money
they could not have 7 with 30 billion
dollars of cash and spend all that money
on purpose so that the government would
bail them out answer this gentleman's
question so the answer is they were to
close their doors they would not have
been to pay their people they would have
all lost their jobs that day the
suppliers who the suppliers were
actually in worse shape than GM and
Chrysler because their business had
fallen off just as much right but they
hadn't gotten the 17 billion dollars at
the end of 2008 so that's why we heard
from the suppliers actually first thing
we in fact did was a supplier kind of
guarantee program which was frankly more
optics than substance because we didn't
feel we could help every company in this
industry but the suppliers were in tough
shape and they would have many most of
them actually did end up going bankrupt
but restructuring in bankruptcy but they
would close their doors the dealers
would have temporarily closed their
doors and you know we can debate the
number and but I think you would have
had a couple million people out of work
very very quickly now your point is
completely right and we did do a lot of
analysis around Chrysler on this point
that obviously people would have picked
up some of that business so for example
and clay will help me
roughly half of the business of a
typical car dealership is actually
repairs it's not selling new cars so
obviously people who still have their
cars repaired so they would if some of
those people would have kept their jobs
have been hired back some part of a car
dealership is selling used cars that
would have continued you are correct
that for example the jeep line that
Chrysler had we thought was worth a fair
amount of money and would be sold to
some European but would they keep making
Jeep in the US where they simply take
the nameplate and make the cars wherever
they happen to be based and send the
cars to the US who knew so you're right
that there would have been a gradual
process you would have had a sort of
one-time loss of this huge number of
jobs and then a gradual process of the
jobs coming back in one form or another
because as you implied in your question
the number of cars that would be sold in
the US would probably not change very
much it's just a question who was going
to sell them but in our view it would
have been a long painful process there
would have been certainly permanent loss
of American jobs because Ford was in no
position Ford was worried that they
themselves were going to go out of
business they were in no position to buy
anything so it probably would have been
some non-us entity and we don't know at
the end of it how many jobs would have
remained just like look we don't know if
we had not bailed out AIG we don't know
what would happen if we had not put the
tarp money into those banks on Columbus
Day that Hank Paulson put the money into
we don't know what would have happened
we just felt it was an unacceptable risk
to take there's some kind of social
experiment to say let's let you know
Chrysler and GM go out of business or
run out of money and then we'll see what
happens we just didn't feel that was the
responsible outcome when we had an
alternative that we felt was financially
viable and relatively small financial
exposure for the American taxpayers the
potential firestorm that the
administration had
we're the sweetheart promote that the
unions got over the bondholders can you
talk a little bit more about the
politics there and giving up
restructuring so when people raise that
issue they're generally talking about
Chrysler and Chrysler Chrysler's capital
structure essentially consisted of 6.8
billion dollars of senior secured
so-called secured debt that was actually
a bunch of banks was forty six or seven
banks there were no bondholders actually
technically in Chrysler and then there
was some second and third lien debt that
was held by a little bit by a de Mille
or a little bit by Cerberus a bunch by
the US government and then obviously
there was equity so the challenge with
Chrysler was that the 6.8 billion
dollars of senior secured debt was not
really secured by anything it was it was
sort of notionally secure but Chrysler
didn't have six point eight billion
dollars worth of assets Chrysler's value
in liquidation was a billion dollars or
less in our opinion and and and JP
Morgan would agree with this so
essentially the question was the first
question was what was the fair recovery
for those banks the debt was trading at
fifteen cents on the dollar that's
roughly a billion dollar valuation as I
said our view was that if we simply
handed the keys to those banks which is
one way to handle a bankrupt situation
they would have not gotten more than a
billion dollars out and probably they've
acknowledged you know where as I when I
talk to them the course during the book
they acknowledge was actually probably
less they would have gotten out so we
paid them in the end two billion dollars
of cash to go you know basically to go
home and it's also normal in a
bankruptcy as you all probably know for
that for the bank's not to get cash but
to get more paper so we actually were
incredibly generous with those banks
relative to what they were entitled to
and in fact Jamie Dimon at JPMorgan when
I talked about this months after it said
to me my problem is not with what we got
I think we were treated fairly my
problems with what the UAW got so well
let's turn to the UAW and I would start
by arguing that frankly
what the UAW got is none of his business
in other words he got at least as much I
would argue substantially more than what
he was entitled to get or would have
gotten under any other circumstances we
made a decision
the UAW had a twelve billion dollar
claim against Chrysler for what was
called a Viva was for the the famous
retiree health care benefits that you've
all read a lot about the company's
actually to their credit had done a good
job before we showed up of putting a box
around these open-ended health care
liabilities and by doing a deal with the
UAW in which they both agreed to put a
fixed amount of money into a trust that
would pay these health care costs and in
return for that that would be all the
companies had to pay that there could be
no further health care retiree health
care liability of the companies in
Chrysler's case it was a twelve billion
dollar obligation they had funded I
think it was there's a billion more they
had funded about a billion i think
anything was twelve billion left it was
an it's an unsecured claim against the
company we could have wiped it out
we could have basically said you're down
in the capital structure I hope this all
makes sense to you guys
I assume you're in business school
hopefully does so we said we could have
wiped that out but we felt that if we
did that we would simply not have
workers to do this job that essentially
this was all part of a negotiation and
in order to reach some we're asking the
UAW to make a lot of sacrifices but
asking them to wipe out all the retiree
health care funds which would affect
obviously the retirees but also the
people who are still working there was
simply a bridge too far and so we
converted half of that into a note and
gave them equity for the other half and
that happened to be 55 percent of the
equity of the company underneath a huge
mountain of debt that was still sitting
on top of it of US government debt and
other debt and our view was that that
equity was not worth a huge amount at
that point in time we hoped it would be
worth more later but we didn't put a lot
of value on it at that moment but we
felt it was something it was important
to do to to have an acceptable
arrangement with the UAW and there is
precedent for this in my my colleague
Ron bloom
my deputy had done a whole bunch of
steel industry bankruptcies and in many
of those many of those actually had
Vitas like Chrysler and in and in those
cases in some of those cases those vbus
also got equity in the company as part
of their compensation and then
restructuring so it was litigated all
the way to the united all through
bankruptcy court all through the court
of appeals all the way to the United
States Supreme Court and essentially
every judge said what we said which was
that the key element is that every
creditor got at least as much or more
than they were entitled to get or would
have gotten in a normal bankruptcy and
the fact that some got more than they
would have you know this much more than
they would have gotten and some of them
got this much more than they would have
gotten isn't really a litigate able
issue everybody got at least as much or
more than they would have gotten and
that's why we thought it was fair and
there weren't there were no politics
around it I mean honest to god I was
never told by the White House to do
anything about the UAW other than what
we did and in fact at one point Ron
Goodell finger wanted to go in and see
the President and Rahm Emanuel and
basically they said look you know the
auto team is doing this and deal with
them yes ma'am
as you want to read this you talked a
little bit about looking backwards at is
it seem a lot of precedent but how did
you think about what you were doing
behind being a potential future model
for similar cases actually we thought
about it a lot and Larry Summers
particularly thought about it our behalf
maybe in the opposite of the way you
mean your question which was we really
did not want to set a precedent for the
government intervening in the private
sector we all thought we were pretty
smart we all thought we knew what we
were doing but none of us but I'm sure
we didn't know as much as we thought we
did but in any event none of us like the
idea that the next group and the next
group of the next group that any
industry could come in and say do for us
what you did for the car companies and
get government money we hated that idea
just the way we hated what my Vietnam
analogy just the way we hated the idea
of having a long term ownership position
in these companies which is part of why
GM when public so quickly was for the
government to be able to sell we really
we view ourselves as investors of last
resort if there had been any private
capital that wanted to come in instead
of us we would have said it's all yours
we didn't want to be here or to do this
and so our goal was to leave as light a
footprint as we could to have to you
know be in and out as quickly as we
could have as little to do with running
these companies as we could to have
these private sector boards and frankly
to set as little a precedent as we could
for future involvement because we
believe rightly or wrongly even as
Democrats that the government to the
maximum extent possible should stay out
of the private sector especially the
industrial sector we didn't believe that
any of us had the wisdom to override the
kind of decisions of investors in the
marketplace and capitalists who were
allocating capital we didn't think the
government should be doing that yes sir
what except were you influenced by that
there are precedents Chrysler was
actually 79 maybe it was 80 and Lockheed
is one Conrail there there are certainly
a few precedents for the government
stepping in under extreme circumstances
we were not particularly influenced by
that early Chrysler precedent and I
would argue that each of those I don't
know enough about all of them to kind of
evaluate whether they were the right or
the wrong thing I would argue that I
hope the people who made those decisions
in those cases basically made the same
decision we made which was it was a
systemic risk call it too big to fail
call it what you want that it was just
too much too much of a risk to put on
the economy at that particular moment in
time but again I think the number of
cases like that is a small handful and I
think it should stay a small handful and
I think it should only happen under the
most extreme circumstances and hopefully
you know part of what I've tried to say
in the book when I try to say in these
talks and what we've said publicly and
the president said publicly is we just
want this to be the exception and not to
have people feel this is the beginning
of you know this is not this is not the
longhand arm of government this is not
creeping socialism this is not Obama
motors this is sort of a decision that
we just had to make but wish we hadn't
had to make
I was a reporter at the New York Times
actually I covered a little bit the
Chrysler bailout in 79 or 80 and you
know during that period there was a lot
of a lot of debate about the Japanese
and whether it was fair trade or free
trade and whether we've kind of been
taken for kind of suckers or not and
there was a look there was some in fact
part of the reason the Japanese started
assembling cars here was they were
afraid that we were going to put import
quotas on them and this and therefore
they they'd be shut out of the market
and so they started but one of the
reasons why they started assembling here
was to avoid that that that possibility
look one of the things and this gets
back to my sort of management matters
theme of that article that you all have
one of the things that struck me in the
course of this is the fact that GM had
this huge problem you know we put fifty
billion dollars into GM GM actually
turned out was in some ways in worse
shape than Chrysler even though even
though as a much bigger kind of company
proportionate to its revenues it got
more capital than Chrysler and so here
you have GM that ran through thirty
billion dollars in 15 months and
literally did show up having run out of
money Ford did get into trouble as I
said you know Ford had a tough at a
tough brush but Ford got through it and
Ford had you know huge profits last year
near record profits last year and never
needed a government handout and so the
question is why why
you know they're playing exactly the
same set of cards right same UAW
contract same Japanese competition or
South Korean competition same oil prices
same credit crisis so why is Ford doing
so well in GM isn't and the only
conclusion I can come to his management
so I can't tell you that every policy
decision the government made over the
last 40 years about autos helped or hurt
it was right or wrong but I do think
that a fair amount of the trouble that
Detroit got into was of its own making
and the difference in how the three
companies went through it does reflect
the quality of management and the
strategic decisions they made along the
way yes sir distinguishes whether this
company's gonna an auto companies gonna
succeed or one why didn't the private
sector step in earlier I mean I could
imagine like a private investor
recognizing that there's a friendly to
pressing value and just in this
particular management stepping in I mean
is there any inefficiency in or takeover
Margaret hairnets
sort of could have prevented this
problem at an earlier stage you know I
don't forgot to prevented the problem I
was with you till that last part but we
can come back to it but one of the
things that Larry Summers and I used to
debate and we're I shouldn't be debating
are some ones about anything but but at
least in this one area I felt like we
were kind of on neutral territory which
was the sort of efficient markets
hypothesis which actually Larry has
argued both sides of at different times
in his career and you know I'm respect
markets I'm a private sector guy but I
also think markets don't always work and
in March of 2009 you could have bought
Ford stock for $1 something it was up to
18 it's now at 14 something so there was
a case where private capital could have
said this is a great opportunity let's
come in and they would have made a lot
of money even when we put well we put 30
billion dollars into GM on of the 50
billion 30 billion winning on June 1st
when GM went into bankruptcy and the
first 20 was kind of lost if you sort of
follow the normal bankruptcy process
that 30 billion was what bought us our
60% of the equity if anybody had showed
up and said I want a piece of that 30
billion we would have said great here
take it you know that 30 billion today
is worth 40 45 billion you know it's not
ten times but it's it was a very good
investment that we made on June 1st so I
I think markets can
in efficient and this I guess is you
know to the good questions that you all
have asked about precedent and about
when the government should intervene
markets do fail and I think you know we
can debate the financial rescue the bank
stuff and I have views about all that
but I think broadly speaking there are
moments when government does have a role
to play when markets do fail when
private capital isn't being allocated
efficiently or intelligently and you see
some of that going on you know Europe is
going to face those decisions over the
next few weeks or what they do a bet
Greece and Portugal enero the same kinds
of decisions so there are tough tough
decisions there really tough decisions I
do think that both the Bush
administration the Obama administration
really got most of them right in this
case but I think these kinds of
interventions should be the exception
not the rule
I think Thanksgivings about I do think
that the notion to be trying to avoid
the necessity of government ever
intervening by reducing every
institution to whatever is considered to
be the maximum size that makes them not
systemic is not practical you know the
example I like to use is LTCM in 1998
was not on anybody's list of the 25
biggest institutions or most important
institutions and it almost brought down
the whole financial system and required
you know a fairly dramatic intervention
the Canadian banking sector is far more
concentrated than our banking sector is
and yet they got through all this
without needing the government
intervened so those are two examples on
either side of the question I think look
I think obviously a lot of mistakes were
made in deregulating the financial
sector it is too integral to be allowed
to just sort of run amok and whether the
dodd-frank stuff and all the pieces of
it the Volcker Rule and so forth are
exactly the right things are not time
will tell but we had you know I think
some of what we did was right but nobody
should kid themselves that that either
dodd-frank or what we did in autos or
breaking these companies down would
avoid the need for government to ever
intervene that's looked as part of why
you have government it's to deal with
extraordinary circumstances and I've
said a couple times I'll say it one last
time what we can all we should all hope
and pray for is that our leaders in the
future are thoughtful about when they do
choose to intervene because I do think
it should be by far the exception and
obviously when you do it you want to do
it right as as I said eyes I think both
administrations have done over the past
couple years